the bikini 3d printer by part 3 D was
designed by us to be the world's
friendliest and easiest to use 3d
printer it's a small compact device
where everything is integrated into just
one unit we design it so that you can
use it from anywhere at iPhone iPad or
your pc or mac right it's fully wireless
the buccaneers intelligent because it
has a little pc inside and a computer so
it does everything for you you just
upload a file and then it just slices
and then it will print for you
the first steps in my design process was
really gathering feedback on what people
actually wanted a 3d printer to be
because you know 3d printers back that
looked ugly they looked mechanical very
industrial it exposed parts hanging out
everywhere so we actually look to our
personal campaign who works in nus get a
nice interesting idea which we tapped on
and then we slowly grew that into the
final design concept which you see today
as a start-up we faced many many many
different kinds of challenges the
challenge was figuring out how to
combine the best of design looks with
mechanical performance in the second
challenge we faced was expertise in
hiring the right people to come in to
work on different segments
initially there wasn't a lot of team
were initially I had to do a lot of the
design conceptualization by myself but
then as time went on right we had
collaboration to other companies which
then helped us flesh out the design more
the greatest functional value of the 3d
printer is what you see in your mind or
on your computer most specifically is
what you get you can produce whatever
you want directly at that point of need
which is in your home
if you let the president's design award
allows aspiring designers and young
people to really have role models to
look at and to emulate when they see
that you know oh the Singapore
government is recognizing me as a
designer now then I have the opportunity
to do good design and this good design
therefore gets recognized my advisor
emerging designers is to really if you
want to go into manufacturing design
specifically a product design is to work
at a product design firm first no
advancement in design comes without an
advancement in manufacturing first and
once you understand these processes then
you can design a groundbreaking product
this is the buccaneer 3d printer design
of the year
you